so let's start off we want to talk about
a little bit this is
this is cool man it seems like every
time you team up with florida georgia
line
it's a hit like it's almost a no-brainer
at this point
you said that they're like family is
this something that you think is going
to be a career-long thing for you that
you'll be
collaborating with them well into the
future um
i don't know man you know what i mean um
you know i'm truly i'm truly thankful
that my fans allow me to
to do certain things like this you know
i mean when it comes to music as far as
being able to be musically free and
do music in different genres and and
still have um
success with it with florida georgia
line they are like family
we've been rocking together now for
about seven eight years
and it's i think it's just one of those
situations to where
you know once you develop a rapport with
certain people in a comfort level
that it can translate that into whatever
you guys do together for a living and i
think it just comes out in our music
because
you know we do appreciate who the
the person is so to speak as opposed to
the artist man they i mean bk
and tyler they they're good they're good
people man and you know their family's
good they care
and they love what they do so i love
what i do and i think
you know for the most part it just comes
out um
in the music so we've been we've been
okay so far
i think we'll see more it'll be it'd be
good to i mean you've been doing
collaboration with country for
for years and i think it's cool that you
mentioned just now your fans
you know you appreciate that they give
you the freedom to be able to do that
but did you ever feel like
in creating music and creating like
hip-hop that you had limitations in
terms of
which direction you could go and how the
sound was going to be i
think um i don't think
i had limitations only because i said
that um
because my the way i came into the game
i think was different because i i was
developing
nelly and nelly's capabilities and not
just what people
are used to from nelly that because
there was no nelly
you know if i think if people would have
had something to compare it to i think
it had been easier to kind of trap it
into a box or say you should go this way
you should go that way
um but the fact that i was able to
you know come in with a broad paintbrush
of of ideas and and then sounds and
and abilities um i think i was able to
you know
capture that type of audience that said
okay well we'll give it a shot
and you know thankfully enough the music
delivered on those type of levels enough
to where people accepted it and
you know you get your fan base that you
do when people accept nelly
um in different ways and in different
genres
yeah and you know this is um a little
bit is off of the new one heartland
and i'm i'm wondering for you like where
does heartland sit
in that you know that new exploration of
where nellie's sound is going next
right well what i say all the time is um
heartland is is a nelly album but it's
country influenced
it's not a country album um
i love country music i respect country
music i respect the art form that is
country music i respect
the artists and what they put into that
i don't live a
country life to to feel like i'm a
country artist
but i have an uh uh love and appreciate
country music and i'm showing how it
influences nelly
and you know i'm giving that respect to
the people that i'm collaborating with
from the country world
and i think you know you can all come
together i think the line
for so long was here when i really think
the line is truly here
because i love for what we do brings us
all together and our love for
celebratory things and having fun and
telling our stories
is is here as well and i think if you
can find that
that middle ground um that a lot of
times i've been able to do when i'm when
i'm coming together with people
um in different genres of music i think
people can appreciate it
you know i think we bring both sides to
the table
in a sense of appreciation i know i have
tons of
hip-hop fans that that that love nelly
that would say man why you know
you turn me on the country music i
listen to these people now listen to
that people now and i think it's the
same way um when i first did over and
over with tim mcgraw i had a lot of
a lot of um country uh fans of mine
saying man you know that tim mcgraw you
know you turned me on to a little bit
more
hip-hop i listened to a little bit more
hip-hop now and i think that's what you
try
to do and i think that's what you want
to do as an artist just to be able to
bring people together and to do things
that
you know other artists can't do but it's
kind of one of the things that music
should do right like you should be
influencing one sound's got to influence
the next and people got to be brought in
from all sorts of walks of life that
you know to explore these sounds but
that's what you hope
i mean you know that's that's the goal
but it that's almost in life
you know you hope you can people yeah
you know but a lot of times those are
barriers up uh some people
don't want it to uh collaborate
you know some want to keep it keep it
totally separate
like that but we all know evolution is
inevitable
people are going to evolve kids are
going to be born listening to both sides
listening to both music therefore when
they get older
their influences are going to cross
brand as well
so um it's just one of those situations
to where you can either
fight it or you know one day
one day it's going you go you'll be left
behind because it's going to happen
it's going to happen well i mean this
all seems very in line with
what you bring to the table because i
mean when we go back to country grammar
this is kind of like what you've been
doing from the very beginning i mean i
remember
when country grammar first came out and
how huge it was
not just because the songs were catchy
but because it's like something new and
different
when you think back to to where you were
at you know
20 years ago when country grammar was
was first hitting
you know what do you remember about
nelly from that long ago
um just wanting to really just
you know do his thing um represent where
where he was from and show that you know
where i'm from
in this country and in this world we we
can make great music too
we can you know we can capture the world
with
how we get down to how we see it and i
think that's just the ultimate
the ultimate thing for when i had
originally came out is
is the fact that people accepted where i
was from and what i was doing
and the sound that i was presenting with
it that's the thing
and once you get that it's a it's a it's
a hell of a feeling
because you feel like wow they heard me
you know and that's what you want the
people to hear you
um and once they hear you you know and
they hear what you're saying then they
can understand you if they can
understand you then they could love you
and that's and that's what i think in
turn was happening with country brahma
the experience that you've had in the
industry you know being in it for so
many years and being like being
successful in it for so many years
do you find that it was um a challenge
to stay true to the way that you wanted
to present
yourself like what advice would you give
to someone who's
maybe funny against being changed or
having their artistic vision compromised
um i mean it's tough i think it it def
it depends on what's playing into
you changing or what's pulling you to
change you know if you're changing
because you want to change
then that's a great thing regardless if
it works or not because at the end of
the day you still doing you
and as long as you know you know you did
what you wanted to do at the
at the end of the day then you know
nobody can ever take that away from you
it's like yo you go out punching
you go out doing what you want to do but
if you're having doubts about it or
you're being pulled in a direction
because
of something else then that's a little
tough because
if it doesn't work then it's almost like
okay you want to blame somebody but at
the end of the day
you can only blame yourself because you
know you're in control of that
so um i just try to tell people stay
true to what you want to do
and make sure nobody is influencing you
in a sense of
trying to make you do anything but if
you but understand if you
make that decision to go that route make
sure that you understand that you're
making that decision
and um you know at the end of the day
you're the one that has to be in control
of your career
because if not then i mean you know you
got nobody to blame but yourself so to
speak
mm-hmm when you're out in the world and
people recognize you
what song do they sing back to you the
most how do you hear from people the
most i mean you know what it's crazy i
think it's more territorial depending on
where you at
and that's a that's a good thing for me
as well because i mean i've been able to
do a lot of great songs and and that's
been totally different like um one of
the things
my songs don't sound like each other
like country grammar don't sound like e
i
e i don't ride with me ride with me
don't sound like hot in here hot in here
don't sound like dilemma
dilemma don't sound like over and over
you know what i mean like so
depending on where you are and which
nelly
and which that we appreciate that's
probably what i get the most you know um
when i'm on tour with the boys uh
florida georgia line a lot
you know you get a lot of the rival
knees and just i guess and it depends on
how old they are too as well i don't
want to go
but i mean it's cool to be able to say
in your career that
it's even to be able to say that like it
depends on how old they are because it
just means that you've had all this
lasting power
what's um what what version of nelly are
you bringing to uh new year's rock and
eve
a little bit of this a little bit of
that
a little bit old nelly man you know i
enjoyed just um
getting up there rocking man um and um
even with the rocket new year's eve
you know i had a chance to had the
pleasure of doing it a few a couple
times now
so every time we get a chance to do it
is is great you know dick clark he's
a huge nelly supporter you know um my
man ryan
i don't want to date him but it feels
like he's been there for every year
every year as well so um you know we're
just going brain nelly man and that's
the good thing it's like no matter which
nelly you get
it's usually a dope time you know what i
mean so
i just appreciate everybody for that
type of love
yeah uh i gotta say i was really
impressed with how well you showed up
for dancing with the stars
you had mentioned like you mentioned in
an interview
like if i had known what i was up
against i wouldn't i wouldn't have done
it
because you don't want to set yourself
up like that yeah like
does it inspire you to maybe like i
don't know get into it more
maybe do more dance lessons well this
well this is the thing it's like
no it it's uh it's it's dancing with the
stars
you know what i mean like so i mean you
know i'm
i'm under the impression that every that
all of us that come on here
or you know what i mean it's kind of
it's kind of like uh
you know if you join a a ymca basketball
league that's supposed to like have no
pros
it's like you know you kind of like okay
there's no pros here
yeah but there's a guy that played at
duke for four years
he's not a pro though but he's been to
an ncaa championship
you kind of like ah okay
but i mean i mean you know i said it in
just but i mean you know be
realistically if i'm
if i'm not a dancer i've never took
taken dance i've never did choreography
a day in my life
you know and then i enter a show where
some of the people may have studied
dance in school
it's kind of like oh wow okay
[Laughter]
but but do that as it may it's taking
nothing away
from how well that they did you know
they did a great job
you know i i said it kind of jokingly i
mean you don't want to go into a
songwriting contest
and know that nellie's in the contest
you know what i'm saying like you find
out
yeah nelly's not in the contest but uh
his uh one of his producers is and he
you know
okay so yeah yeah but um
no man it was a dope experience man i
had a great time
and shout out to everybody and caitlyn
who won man she danced beautifully
she danced her butt up and it was it was
it was dope watching her
and you know everybody that participated
it was it was a dope experience and i
and i think it pushed me it did push me
you can't
i mean there's no other way i mean as a
competitor once you find out what you're
really
up against then it's kind of like no one
oh but you got to understand i'm
learning dances in a week
i'm trying to learn and now i'm trying
to learn two dances in a week
so yeah it was that was tough man it was
tough but
i had so much fun